good morning everyone so um yes it's a
pretty big talk so I'm just gonna kind
of just dive in plow through it's my
third party and I'll cry if I want to
and I warned you I might actually cry
because this is 45 minutes covering the
dangers the perils the app - minefield
that is third-party performance I'm
willing to bet that anyone in here who's
ever worked on even the smallest of
websites will have used one if not
handful of third parties because mainly
because of convenience we might not want
to build our own analytic package we
might not want to do our own image
transformers we might not have the
knowledge to provide a comment system
that discuss might give us so of
convenience and usually cost-saving we
will use a third party but then we begin
to relinquish quite a lot of control by
taking the convenient sort of route we
have to start giving something back and
usually that is relinquishing control
and accepting some risk before I get
into the talk proper I try to come back
to this oh this is my third time in
Toronto now and I just find this city
actually wonderful I haven't really
spent enough time here I just bite
having dessert three times but I think
this is really true I really adore the
tech scene here I think it's a really
sort of icon it's a great first ago
appetite nothing sort of proves that to
me quite like this I saw on my way here
this morning website just the word not a
question is not a question
website no yes it's just just a word
website no it's a distinct lack of web
address just a vague physical kind of
I'm here for the website I think so yeah
you know keep flying that flag Toronto
that's that's there's don't is anyone
seen this there staple for the blunt
posts all around the building anyway
yeah I'm Harry
I won't sort of do much of an intro you
only need one I'm a consultant
performance engineer it's my job to help
my clients clients like these I've had a
really very fortunate career usually
quite big clients because they feel the
benefits of performance the most helping
people like this have faster websites
nearly every single person on this
organisation on this slide has had some
kind of perform
slow down I'd say more than half of them
have suffered third party performance
degradation now when I was researching a
talk about third party performance my
mind immediately went back about ten
years honestly it's as long as that to a
news story from Australia and the reason
I was reminded of this news story is
well it has three similar sort of themes
with my talk it deals with parties
uninvited guests and also financial
repercussions unsuspecting parents are
on holiday
sixteen-year-old Cory Worthington is now
facing not only the wrath of Mum and Dad
but a twenty thousand dollar fine from
police I spoke to him a short time ago
sorry thanks for joining us the only
question that I can think to ask is what
were you thinking I wasn't really did
your parents say you could have a party
no so didn't why did you um I know just
to get together with a couple mates at
first and then we thought we might as
well just have a bit of a party and then
it sort of just got out of hand and yeah
I [ __ ] hate i guy guys so much um but
that last sentence oh it kind of got out
of hand I mean one understatement of the
century
cost his parents 20 grand but then it
reminded me of something else this made
me realise that yeah it got out of hand
I mean pretty severely but most of the
performance issues we get on the web or
just things getting out of hand people
losing sight of things losing track of
things nobody on purpose builds our slow
websites
nobody you know marketing teams on
purpose overload the front end with tags
and scripts and third parties to make a
slow website usually people just lose
track of things a client got in touch
with me last year saying hey we've got
some kind of performance issues and I
believe they may be down to third
parties and I was like send it over you
know nothing scares me I've seen it all
around some tests webpagetest you've
probably ever heard of it run some tests
and this one did scare me I thought I'd
seen it all this was something a bit
different so the green is what the
client the developers believe
built what was getting sent to customers
was a little more like this
I'll get comfortable and then this made
me think actually the biggest problem
with third-party performance is usually
a disconnect because it is true the
green is what the web developer built
it's what the team had built that's what
they spent their day working on but as
soon as this site goes live it's a very
different beast normally your production
environment is very very different to
your development environment and that's
usually because it's not until you're in
live that your tag manager kicks in your
ad networks are used your analytics your
run data is being collected developers
very rarely interface with the actual
live version of a website they get a
nice fast local version it doesn't have
all this stuff loaded into it what
happened here is a tag manager simply
ran a mock and the sort of I guess the
marketing team or whoever is responsible
for that tag manager they don't we know
how far was too far now can I have an
honest show of hands who is not really
familiar with what a tag manager is but
be honest if there's a few people I'll
do a quick intro that's enough hands
that I'll give a quick intro to tag
managers picture the scenario you're a
front-end developer and your manager or
your client asks you hey can you put
Google Analytics on this light so you
copy and paste the snippet and that's
fine a few days later they're like hey
can you install this little a be testing
tool on their site and you say well I
can but I'm kind of busy right now I put
it on the backlog and I'll get around to
it and the marking team get a bit
frustrated this shouldn't take so long
so somebody in their infinite wisdom
invented something called the tag
manager so now what happens is the
marketing team asks you hey can you put
Google tag manager or a Dobby tag
manager on the site and that's just one
small innocuous javascript file but that
javascript file is a conduit which goes
to like a an admin interface some IRA
GUI that someone logs into and they can
put whatever they want in the site
through the tag manager so if they want
to put a Facebook tracking pixel sure
enough they can go to the Facebook
developer Docs copy and paste the
JavaScript put it in their tag manager
this is all production JavaScript it's
not production quality JavaScript - oh
no but it's going to production
completely circumventing the development
process developers don't see this
happening it could be something like the
Facebook track
pixal it could be google analytics it
could also be your marketing team
googled something found a 13 year old
forum post and whoa I'll take that that
should work it could be anything all and
largely skipped the dev process which is
usually why I get a phone call to come
and fix this so anyway this talk is huge
so I'm going to try and whizz through
four key areas first understand what
risks do third parties pose secondly
auditing how do we measure that risk
thirdly how do we discuss that risk how
do we bring that up with third-party
providers and our own internal teams
this is probably the most difficult part
of the whole process involves emotions
and people and finally mitigation how
can we design around it how can we
safeguard this so understand there are
many different ways in which a third
party could affect our performance or
effective negatively in general I'm
gonna start with the one I know least
about just get over and done with
security I'm not a security engineer and
over a little about security but it's a
huge sort of aspect of third parties
because you're inviting someone onto
your page right you're inviting onto
your site and largely it's just down to
trust I trust that Google Fonts isn't
gonna all of a sudden one day start
sending me crypto mining stuff right
which Trust so make sure you're always
pull things from secure origins it's a
small one but if you're getting mixed
content warnings that's going to erode
consumer trust you're not going to put
your credit card details into a site
with chrome is saying hey this site is
insecure it's just a good idea always
pull things from a secure origin
anything that is coming from an insecure
origin is susceptible to potential
man-in-the-middle attack that third
party could be tampered with it could be
compromised in some way some
man-in-the-middle attacks can be
friendly so like Google's data saver
proxy service for example if you're on
an insecure connection they could
reoptimize your images for you but still
insecure content is prone to these kind
of problems and bad actors could run a
mock there could be a scumbag e third
party it's absolutely possible a third
party is not a good actor we said right
at the beginning well a nice talk sorry
about using an airplane Wi-Fi now I'm I
can't believe we can fly so having like
Internet up there I always buy the Wi-Fi
I always buy the Wi-Fi I can't get my
head around
last year or maybe the year before I was
flying - I look really creepy they're
just staring over dev tools that you all
I was flying to Iceland and this is a
transitional period where you could
optionally visit my site via either
secure or an insecure connection Iceland
there were man in the middling me
advertising to me annoyingly I deleted
most of the ads from this screen shot to
make it look tidier then I realized that
it was actually way more impactful when
you could see across the top
it had a big thing saying you know but
Kiev kind of buy your food get a drink
for free whatever loads of ads
man-in-the-middle in me but the main
performance concern I've got is this if
you look at the protocol column they're
downgrading me if I proxy service is
downgrading me to an H or one point zero
connection just sweet just slipping
pelipper switching this to a secure
connection immediately put me through
cloud flies h2 much much faster a couple
years ago YouTube got busted and this is
truth serving crypto mining ants to
customers u2 was recently caught
displaying ads that covertly leech off
visitors CPUs and electricity in order
to generate digital currency on behalf
of anonymous attackers so there is a
chance that the person you've trusted
YouTube they might be hosting ads that
are run by someone who isn't quite so
nice and then rinsing you for CPU cycles
to try and make crypto so at a minimum
pull everything from secure origins make
sure your third parties
always send you secure responses and
this has like a knock-on performance
effect TLS everywhere
gives you access to web platform
features that you wouldn't normally be
able to have otherwise we're looking at
things like h2 serviceworker and broadly
performance oriented features which are
only available to secure connections the
next risk we've got is delays it doesn't
take me to tell a roomful of performance
and engineers that delays it bad Chinese
money these delays could come in a few
different guises we could have on the
network we could have slow downs we
could have a high latency connection
between our first and third party origin
third party infrastructure could be
suffering an outage or it could be Dendy
dosed for example and then there's often
overlooked aspect of runtime cost by
runtime we could be talking JavaScript
or we could be talking really
addley optimized images and so whatever
lands on the device may not be optimal
either this is me quoting a friend /
client for an online client called Ryan
he's the CTO of a an e-commerce startup
and this is him quoting a discussion he
had with a third-party provider so this
is a third-party provider with whom they
spend thousands of pounds a year and
they were worried that this third-party
provider was running slowly so they got
on a phone call with them the
third-party provider naively responded
oh there is zero performance overhead to
using our synchronous script our typical
response time is around 200 milliseconds
I pick one is it zero or is it 200
milliseconds right can't be both three
milliseconds is a eon it's such a long
time when we talk about performance
optimization a client of mine train line
from the UK they've worked out if they
could reduce latency by 300 milliseconds
they could see an uptick in 8.1 million
pounds worth of customer spend a year so
proportionately 200 milliseconds would
be worth five point four mil to this
company moba find that for a hundred
millisecond decrease they saw a 1.1
percent increase in conversion so 200
milliseconds converts to or equates to
over three-quarters of a million dollars
a year not as impressive 55.4 but your
attorney knows it but three quarters of
a mil right this is my favorite this is
staggering walmart found for every
hundred millisecond improvement in
performance it led to an up to one
percent improve improvement in in
revenue I did a bit of crude maths right
I just could Google some Stefan Walmart
2017 ecommerce only revenues were so
high that a two percent 200 millisecond
increase in revenue would equate to an
extra two hundred and thirty million
dollars increased revenue a year but 20
milliseconds didn't seem so innocuous
anymore let's go one worse what happens
if there isn't a slowdown what happens
if there's a full-on outage on a third
party origin it leads to a single point
of failure I've witnessed this happen
for real sort of in real time with
clients of mine while I've been in our
office
worst case scenario what happens when a
third party goes down completely I want
to show
actually happened to a client of mine
it's a company called sky in the UK big
broadcaster notice the address bar I've
made a secure connection to sky comm
I've connected to that that origin look
at the title tab it just says the web
address right no text in the title tab
we look down here we've got a pending
script it's just going to say pending
for the next one point three minutes
what's happened is a view source and
it's important to make the text a little
larger we've got a synchronous
third-party script on a different origin
that is currently suffering an outage
the parser is stuck on line 9 and it
cannot progress to line 11 where the
title tag lives that's why we can't show
the user anything in the title bar
because the parser is stuck on a
synchronous third-party script tiny tiny
little user facing optimization put your
title tag above all your third-party
assets in your head just so we can avoid
this you'll see a hundred percent of the
HTML payload has arrived we should be
showing content to users immediately why
not this third-party outage is having a
severe impact on this client what's
going to happen is after a while
Chrome's built in timeout who's gonna
fire
it's around 80 seconds 1.3 minutes I
can't I don't believe there was any kind
of like spec as to how long each browser
or platform should wait before it times
out chrome seems fairly consistent at
one point three minutes I actually made
my client sit through this video here we
go 1.3 minute Dom content 1.3 minute
load but flat entire 1.3 minutes we
showed the customer nothing at all not
even a title par in a title in the
address bar right really severe this
problem isn't unique to Adobe tag
manager it's not unique to this client
of mine this is just behavior that the
web or browsers this is expected
behavior if you link to font Google API
comm as most of us probably do you stand
to suffer the exact same fate if they
have an outage a synchronous third-party
blocking asset if it has an outage can
lead to severe load times so I was on
site with a different client while it
was happening to them and global average
load times went up to a hundred seconds
a synchronous third polite script that
was currently having an outage had now
wait for two days
so we obviously just pulled it and
didn't have that third party script for
two days that's huge right two-day
outage need to audit this stuff we need
to find out what's going on and feed it
back to people so I've got a very
rigorous very sort of formulaic
repetitive almost approach to
performance auditing I'm going to share
some of the things I do when it comes to
specific third party audits and the very
first thing I will do is just get a very
very broad strokes idea of the general
impact of third parties across the
entire site if you've got your phone
handy take a picture of the next slide
it's one of my favorite little tools
we're gonna be using request map the
slides are online already so you don't
need to worry too much but you're gonna
get an early sort of preview this is a
really great tool we will loop back to
this in a second I'm going to take you
on a bit of a departure that is very
specific to my workflow or never I work
with our client the very first thing I
will do is just run loads of tests so I
will go off and fire a bunch of
webpagetest from the relevant context
browsers geographic locales connection
speeds etc just gonna grab the ID of the
first test that I run I plug that into
request map this is a bit long-winded
you don't have to do it this way but
it'll make sense shortly plug-in to
request map and then we get this but my
clients and I have lovingly dubbed the
jellyfish now this is a really great bit
of database for marketing teams and that
that always sounds really patronizing
but what I mean by that is it's really
good for non-technical folks to get a
rough idea of what's going on the size
of each blob represents the amount of
bytes or kilobytes or having four bit
megabytes from each origin the distance
between the blobs represents the mean
time to first byte or the latency
between those origins and the thickness
of the lines between the blobs
represents the number of requests
between those origins
now we're engineer is right we want data
so this is great for sort of data vis
but we want the raw data which is handy
because right here we can download the
CSV it gives us this little spreadsheet
format don't laugh at me I don't like
much awk I don't think anyone does but i
cobbled this little one-liner together
so once you've downloaded that CSV copy
and paste this from the slides
run lists from your command line this
will just extract every third party
domain from that CSV file it will give
you a plaintext list every third party
domain then what we can do is go back to
webpagetest and what I tend to do is
just block all of them to start with
I've pasted all of those origins into
this lovely little Advanced Settings
block feature this prevents webpagetest
from dispatching requests to any of
these origins this is very heavy-handed
what I'm doing here is saying get rid of
all third parties but what you tend to
do is think um I think the moat ads is
particularly troublesome so I will just
block that one but I do have like a
really broad strokes walk them all see
what happens this gives me a good idea
of do we need to have a conversation at
third parties at all is there actually a
problem this is CNN's website and
everybody always uses CNN in performance
talks they should by now have the
fastest website in the world but they
don't um
sorry so hidding see load time is quite
severely impacted by third parties this
means if we've got any first party
things waiting for the load event
perhaps a lazy loader for our images
that events not going to happen it's
been pushed back quite severely by third
parties quite optimistically though we
can see that start rendering speed index
on to adversely affected so we can kind
of roughly proxy the fact that well
blocking rendering for third party
content or certainly not severely
however if we look at metrics like
number of requests request went up by
four point two times here a factor of
four point two now over h2 and multiple
origins number of requests is becoming
less of an issue on low powered devices
and negotiating and opening so many TCP
connections is going to drain battery
it's just generally not great if we look
at data transfer we'll see that page
weight was increased by a factor of two
point seven when we had all third
parties enabled there's not any effect
as in this room but um as of 2015 so
semi recent study twenty percent of
British people still use a pay-as-you-go
data plan they pay for every single
megabyte they download paying for stuff
it's probably just tracking them around
the internet and showing them ads for
things are not interested in is to me
somewhat immoral I landed yesterday in
pearson and
turn my phone on and I didn't realize
that I don't actually have data roaming
in Canada with one of my particular SIM
cards so I got a notification saying hey
you've used 80% of our allowance and
it's about to start costing you 6 pounds
per megabyte this page is 2.7 times more
expensive than it should be for me stuff
like this is somewhat immoral and this
is why I completely understand people
using ad blockers and stuff like that
all right this is very extreme very
non-scientific but this gives me a good
grounding this allows me to work out how
much of an issue third parties might be
for my particular client doing a bit
more forensic when we look at slow
origins a really good question to ask is
what happens if Typekit is running
slowly
what happens if Optimizely is running
slowly really good question to ask a
very simple to answer there's a tool
called Charles proxy anybody use Charles
before quite a few of us that's great
Charles is free in the same way that
sublime text is free if you know what I
mean by totally recommend grabbing a
copy of Charles it's really really
powerful it's an actually it's a network
proxy right I don't use it for proxying
stuff I tend to use it for its
throttling feature we've got very crude
very coarse throttling available to us
in Chrome's dev tools one of my favorite
little articles is actually by Pat about
better quality throttling and Chrome's
dev tools is quite coarse so using
something that sits closer to the
network such as wind shaper for a
Windows machine or network link
conditioner for a Mac or Charles across
all platforms much better more accurate
network that's off throttling what I
like about Charles is we can enable it
only for specific hosts this means that
we can just slow down my CDN or I could
just slow down my tag manager and see
what happens then let's go one further
what happens if one of these third part
isn't running slowly what happens if
it's gone completely so you know what
happens if Adobe tag manager is having
an outage why haven't it Google Fonts is
having an outage again thanks to Pat
we've got access to web page tests
blackhole server I'm not sure if that IP
address is current is that correct
currently
yeah cool right so yeah that's pretty
good idea
so don't scribble this down just yet
I'll need to collect these slides if
it's different but basically this
simulates an outage any traffic that go
through this server just kind of
disappears it stimulates full-on outages
this is actually how I simulated this
test this screenshot interestingly
enough Google Fonts they don't have an
SLA so I was working with a really big
client and part of the core business is
customer's ability to use custom fonts
and they're all provided through Google
Forms so I asked the engineer's okay
what's your mitigation sort of like
strategy what happens if they go down
what's the SLA with Google Fonts because
as far as I'm aware Google Fonts don't
provide an SLA and my client was like
what's an SLA yeah the SLA service level
agreement what happens at Google Fonts
Goes Down turns out nothing they don't
owe you a penny they don't owe you an
apology
Google Fonts is a free service and it's
a great service but if you're hinging
your entire business around them and
they go down they're going to give you
one foot three minute load times and
they don't owe you a single apology for
that actually you can't get historical
uptime information there isn't a static
Google Fonts com address you can visit
so I actually reached out to somebody
out of Google Fonts just to get some
information interestingly enough since
the service was launched they have not
had a single millisecond of downtime so
statistically Google Fonts is an
incredibly safe service but if anything
was to happen this is what would their
knock-on effect would be for your
customers I need to hurry up missing
files so we've looked at network delays
and outages what happens if the files
missing or corrupt when it arrives what
happens if there is a agility in your
code base or your front-end that means
that missing files are kind of
potentially troublesome Jake Archibald
said and I completely agree with them he
said a few years ago all of your users
are non draya's users while they are
downloading your JavaScript in every
page load life cycle every single
visitor is for a brief period hopefully
a brief period and non JavaScript user
until that javascript has been
downloaded successfully executed
successfully
everyone's an Evan than on Jays user
semi controversial opinion of mine is I
don't believe we should optimize for the
non JSU's case I knew who turned Jobs
ripped off and knew what they were
getting into my like defense of this
sort of it's not too controversial
nowadays but um I'm willing to bet that
your site has more ie6 users than it has
non jf users and your ru six strategies
probably know we optimized for a smaller
percentage of your customer base you've
got javascript disabled then it would be
to optimize for say are you six that
doesn't mean you should just go sort of
willy-nilly gung-ho and not care at all
I think we should optimize for the use
case or at least build for the use case
of what happens if that javascript fails
and it failed reliably can it fail
safely anecdotal but this is a really
interesting and to me cuz i'm a nerd
quite an amusing story a few years ago
there was a massive problem across the
internet where um t-mobile's proxy
servers so most telcos will proxy the
data you're consuming through their own
servers and make optimizations for you
and they will look at an image and maybe
recompress it and pass it on they will
check to see if text assets have been
compressed and if not they all compress
them and pass them on now t-mobile's
proxy server was a bit overzealous with
its comment stripping it popped open
jQuery in photo
there's a massive comment right in the
middle of jQuery founder slash on a star
start and deleting problem is it wasn't
a comment it was a regular expression it
was a slash star in a string and never
found the corresponding closing comment
so the basic you've just trimmed off
two-thirds of jQuery yeah great Jaykar
is two-thirds third of the size it was
but it's not very functional and it
broke the web for hundreds of thousands
of people for several days because they
were just over zealously stripping stuff
out so I'd know TLS everywhere prevents
this they can't proxy if you wanna go
through secure connection so another
soft +1 for TLS everywhere well client
of mine built an entirely client
rendered JavaScript application I've got
an entire talk that thought I could just
give probably over a few beers the
leaked client rendered JavaScript
application and they hadn't considered
the use case what if something goes
wrong
what if the JavaScript has a fatal error
what if something goes wrong
modern tooling makes it dead simple to
work out how you can recover from this
right-click on the asset in question
block request URL subsequent page
refreshes will not request that asset so
you can find out what happens if your
main bundle is missing or malformed my
client just showed an infinite loading
spinner not great we should have done
some defensive programming to say unless
we've successfully booted the
application give a warning that says hey
something's gone wrong really sorry bit
embarrassing but refresh the page do
something somethings better than this I
really don't I forgot time that I'm
gonna indulge myself I was working with
a client last year and they're pretty
big in character based in England but
they're pretty big in Canada video
streaming reality TV service again fully
client rendered JavaScript application
we did some performance changes and
rolled a release but somehow a package a
small JavaScript dependency got version
bumped and the version bump happens to
have a pretty severe error a date object
was getting returned as a string only
and as a fatal error only in specific
flavors of iOS so it's very small subset
of users but those users took to Twitter
right they just start tweeting oh yeah
service is terrible it doesn't work on
my phone this one small error in a
third-party sort of dependency was fatal
enough that the entire application
completely failed to load on certain
flavors of iOS we haven't designed
around the fact that what if that
happens I think the last thing in terms
of auditing is looking at runtime cost
how expensive is this stuff when it
arrives and to get a good proxy or a
good sort of handle on this again quite
coarse information but we really get the
starting point open the page you're
interested in we run a performance
profile and in the bottom you're gonna
find the summary panel and the summary
panel is a small sub panel called bottom
up and then select group by domain
basically it gives you this view this
tells you which domains are or which
attributable domains are the most
expensive in terms of runtime cost for
this particular page this is a client
rendered react application so it
completely to me makes sense that the
first part
the JavaScript is the most expensive so
I'm feeling quite safe here I'm thinking
you know what we are the most expensive
origin that makes sense however if we
have to swap this from group by domain
to group by URL something pretty
surprising happens Google tag manager
has more runtime cost than the core
reactive library something very severe
is coming out of tag manager this
particular one file is of interest to us
now what I like about this view is it
updates in real time as you can scrub if
you look at the graph up here you can
see my cursor is moving updates in real
time and what do is I'll restart this
intertwined point out yeah while the
page is initializing Google tag manager
took number one spot
somehow we're giving more CPU cycles to
third-party content ahead of first party
the learning here is less defer the
third point is maker we've dealt with
first party stuff first do third party
after oh right discussion this is I
hinted at before probably the most
difficult part of the entire process
because some technical problems have
technical solutions you can't rock up to
your marketing team and tell them hey
everything you do every single day makes
this site fractionally worse it's not
gonna wash right it's not it's not gonna
get you many friends it's not going to
be very productive and it's what I'm
hired to do I have those conversations
cause my clients like the engineering
team don't want to so I've worked some
kind of strategies into my workflow
which are take the edge off telling
someone that their jobs basically
worthless it's a joke marketing teams
aren't worthless that was a joke nearly
every time every client will tell me
some flavor of this oh they're a
necessary evil we don't want to use it
what we have to do I think this is lazy
this is the height of laziness it just
sweeps the problem under the carpet it's
their way of saying don't want to talk
about it
thing is it's nowhere near as black and
white as that that's very artsy that
isn't it black and white we need to
actually dissect what we mean when we
say necessary and Neal some things could
be both they could be neither Google
Fonts absolutely not necessary we can
make a functional website without a
custom font but definitely not evil
crypto mining software
not necessary not further customer at
least it's definitely evil so we need to
actually be a little more sort of um I
know crit self-critical I guess or
self-aware actually drill down what we
mean when we talk about in necessary
evils once we've started to identify
things the easiest people to discuss
with and I got pit row that one of the
easiest people to talk about or sort of
discuss this with is gonna be the
third-party vendor it's their job to
provide resilient reliable code for us
so it's quite easy to have those
discussions because it's their
responsibility however vendors can
sometimes be a bit of a black box you
might not always have direct line in if
it's a third party with whom oh no sorry
I'm skipping ahead of myself um advice
for discussing issues with third parties
is a formal hypothesis you will have an
inkling you'll have an idea that a
particular third party is slow and
you're probably correct but point two is
a critical gather the data make triple
sure that you're correct nothing more
embarrassing and ringing someone saying
yeah you're [ __ ] and they tell you that
you know you've implemented it wrong
right
triple check that you are correct triple
check that they are the problem and once
you've got that data replicable
repeatable demonstrably data let them
know now this is the difficult bit
because unless you spend a lot of money
with that third party you might not have
a direct line in it might be careful
opening support tickets or checking out
community forums if it's something like
Google Analytics if it's a CDN or like
an image transform service and you spend
maybe tens of thousands a month with
that company there's every chance
there's someone you can call it there's
every chance it will be an account
manager who will actually help you
triage and assess and fix these problems
I do this in my work quite a lot I'll
know it's performance degradation zin
sort of libs that my clients are using
so I'll just go and submit performance
patches I'll just do the work myself
feed it back in that way and if all else
fails step 4
send them a tweet people panic when it's
on Twitter if it's in a support if it's
a support thing it just goes in to
support you it feels tweeting about it
people listen it sounds very
tongue-in-cheek and it does sound a bit
trite but I would honestly I would
consider this as a genuine strategy my
ad provider have got a little ad in the
sidebar on my site by all accounts a
really nice company I've used them
years I sent them a tweet hey can you
just stick rel equals no opener
alongside your target blanks it's good
for performance good for security
six weeks later there's life done right
just asked DHL shipping company they
were running an application that they
weren't forcing it over a secure
connection HTTP was there was available
they just weren't forcing their
customers there and they were taking
customer data ping them a tweet hey can
you force us on to ask your connection
about two weeks later dan um lo time
right so I've got no idea who this is
your third parties have their own third
parties and colloquially typically we
refer to these as fourth fifth sixth
parties low time was a fourth party on
my site I don't know who they are but
they were being called by one of my
third parties tweeted at them saying hey
can he force this over a secure
connection their CTO got in touch
perfect you can panic the CTO nailed it
fixed in no time
um one thing I will say and I need to
point this out before anyone else does
it's what bluetick does help but my
point is it just start somewhere saying
something is way better than saying
nothing oh let's give it a go fire them
at we do it in good faith you know
trying offer the solution if you know
what the solution is but starting
somewhere is better than doing nothing
all yea the tough one the difficult bit
is discussing this stuff with internal
teams actually going to a marketing
department and saying look I get the job
is to do this stuff we need to measure
things there is absolutely value in
having run data analytics data right you
know there's definitely value in having
some third parties so we can't just go
in and remove more we need to have a bit
of a discussion about understanding what
they are one of the techniques I use
most frequently is I go back to the
little jellyfish from earlier and that
CSV file that we downloaded I've built a
little Google sheets template into which
you can import that CSV data it will
just categorize and sort of highlight
problem areas the Google sheet is a
template that is freely available
there's a there's a big link to it in a
couple of slides time this is my site
very few third parties on my site
anything yellow is a duplicate this can
tell you oh we've got
five ad networks we've got three
analytics packages anything red is a
degree of severity in sort of gradiated
fashion so white is completely not
nothing to panic about at all and the
darker red the worst is until it's solid
red and that's you're worse than 90th
percentile so here's where you'd start
focusing your attentions this is an
oddly specific thing I'm about to show
you next but if you want to use this
template you will need to memorize or at
least refer to the slides for this bit
when you drop your own data in here you
have to do it in a specific manner so
the CSV file you got from the jellyfish
thing
file import navigate to that CSV file
here's the important bit replace data at
selected cells so when you replicate
this yourselves
make sure you refer to this slide
replacing data selected cell ensures
that your conditional formatting sits on
top of your new data if you just pop it
into a brand new sheet in that
spreadsheet it would be numbers it
wouldn't look like anything so CNN we
will see you looks more like this
looking to start to see that we've got a
allegedly only one tank manager but more
than one a be testing tool more than one
affiliate marketing platform there's a
really important column in here that's
currently empty column H notes this is
what I will do when I work with
marketing teams and sort of like a
whoever that may be in the business I'll
go and ask them stuff the key point
it sort of in the workflow right here is
Ask Don't Tell don't rock up saying look
how scary this spreadsheet is I'm
deleting everything on Monday go and say
from hey can you tell me why do we use
this what our third point is do we use
can you explain the relevance of this
one for example
so yeah arrange a meeting gather the
data organize a meeting huh no we don't
like meetings but it's important ask
questions get insights there is a reason
why your company needs a tag manager
because they want to do stuff maybe you
can help them do it better maybe you can
help them do it faster work out what
problems are trying to solve and see if
you can solve it in a neater first-party
fashion or you might know a fact you
might know of a um a different third
party that is maybe cheaper or better or
it's thought about performance so to
find out what they're trying to solve
how
and achieve it um bunch of questions
here I'm not gonna go through each one
of them but the last one is quite
interesting
are there any services in here that we
don't recognize there's always at least
one oh yeah never heard of that one
right well we've got an account for it
no knows what it is like spin it like to
get rid of it I'm gonna tell you another
story cuz I'm treating myself I guess I
was working with a client last year and
they had a third party and I didn't I
was a bit sneaky about this I put in
their little engineering slack Channel
hey um can we get rid of this third
party and the the product owner is like
absolutely not definitely not can't get
rid of that we spend a lot of money on
that we need that so we can't get rid of
that I was like are you sure we can't
get rid of it I'd like to get rid of it
absolutely not no question that we
cannot get rid of it and that's what I
decided to tell them it's never worked
when you copied and pasted the embed
code out of Outlook it converted you're
straight programmer quotes into curly
quotes which meant that this has
literally never worked it's a syntax
error this file has never once been
downloaded this third party has never
once functioned on your site in the head
I did a get log and sort of for the
history of this snippet all the way back
to the date was installed it never once
in three years being functional they
didn't paying for it god that's what
they thought it was doing he wasn't
giving them anything but no we can't get
rid of that what we already did by
accident three years ago so it's gone
and so yeah if you want to take a
picture of this feel free this is a link
to that Google sheet that template the
slides already online for like I say
don't panic too much but yeah start
dropping your own data over the top of
this you'll get lots of nice information
well with five minutes to go who need to
do the whole fourth section of the talk
mitigate how do we design around this
how do we build resilient lis how do we
build defensively first bit of advice
simplest bit of advice self host self
host as much stuff as you can I'm
working with a client at the moment and
their immediate optimization even before
we sign any paperwork to work together I
just sent them an email saying get all
of your stuff off of these third-party
CD ends don't link to J s delivery or
whatever is don't use mat CD ends
bootstrap bring all of this stuff onto
first
coffee's it's gonna solve so many
problems it's gonna make your site a lot
more resilient and a lot faster so self
host as much as you can even if it is a
third-party asset hosted it on a
first-party origin that still counts as
self hosting a self host as much as you
can it means you've got the controlled
infrastructure if you've got an outage
you've got your own outage to worry
about if you're running fine and your
tag manager is having an outage that's
when the frustration sets in you get
reduced network negotiation no opening
new connections etc you can dictate your
own caching strategy and you can use
things like preload to preload things
that you know you will need so where
possible self host any critical assets
not always going to be possible but
anything that is on the critical path
anything that blocks rendering always
try and get that onto your own origin
load anything asynchronously so any
asynchronous loading method that a third
party provides use that right and if
they don't provide an asynchronous
loading method that's a red flag for me
that is a warning but they haven't fully
considered the impact of if they have an
outage an example with sky the tag
manager it might not always work because
you probably will get sort of race
conditions and sort of syntax errors but
the fix for this was just make it
asynchronous
if load your tag manager asynchronously
yeahyou tag manager is for tracking
users right or maybe retargeting them or
whatever is your tag manager goes
offline and blocks the site one point
three minutes you've got nothing to
measure anyway always load things like
this asynchronously don't block the
primary purpose because there's no point
in measuring it when it's broken that
results hints so we can use resources
like pre connect to actually mitigate a
lot of the loss of pay up front for the
network negotiation costs so we can use
pre connect to do things like well what
I'd recommend is just take a look at a
typical page on your site identify
third-party providers get a list of
origins list of domains and pre connect
them what this will do is we'll deal
with that network negotiation ahead of
time my sight before I am this is years
old years old but my sight before I
implemented pre connect all of this
expensive network negotiation is
happening very very just in time this is
the least opportune time to deal with
this stuff switching off to
reconnecting these origins we can sort
of swallow that cost much sooner and off
of the critical path or at least take
out of the way of all these our third
party so that's what critical path but
it's all of that cost sooner word of
warning no don't go crazy with this
don't want every single thing don't warm
up fourth parties only warm up things
you know are going to be important to
the page frequently used etc one minute
42 seconds to look at CSP anybody using
CSP in production content security
policy relatively new CSP ones quite
mature actually what this does it's a
header that defines what kinds of
content different origins can load so
what you can do here is say the only
third party that I've allowed to use run
JavaScript is Google Analytics this
means that Google Fonts isn't gonna
start sending you JavaScript for some
reason this allows you to whitelist
domains and what content they can send
to you if they send a JavaScript file
but they haven't been white listed for
JavaScript just error right console will
give you a warning it'll say this hasn't
worked it violates CSP CSP one pretty
mature I tried to move them implementing
it on my site and even with a handful of
third parties it becomes really hard to
pin down what a legitimate sort of good
actors and bad actors where CSP defines
what kind of content can be loaded it
doesn't actually define what that
content can do so you might white list
the domain set yeah send over some
driver trip for analytics but what if
they get compromised and all of a sudden
it's a mining crypto or it's tracking
people's geolocation a new spec feature
policy fills that gap and it allows you
to pinpoint or it's off whitelist what
features are available every site should
have this by default no one's using a
microphone no one's using my camera
knowns using geolocation we don't need
it you know auto-playing anything so
feature policy allows us to actually pin
down what that what those assets can do
after they've arrived very very it's in
its infancy I guess so can't be used
that much but keep an eye on it's a
pretty interesting policy sub resort
integrity SR I allows you to actually
verify the file you've request that is
the one you expected
looks like this you get an integrity
attribute this is a sha-256
sort of checksum of the file which is
then passed through basics before
happen is when the file arrives the
browser will check the checksum against
the file actually arrived this means
that if some little script Kitty hacked
jQuery the CDN and for something
malicious in there this file changed you
know for a fact that something's gone on
and the browser will refuse to execute
this a set s RI pretty good it's pretty
decent support so ya start using it a
lot of responsible third parties will
give you an s RI token anyway last thing
I think I promise I'm now 42 seconds
over and professional priority hints
relatively new spec Pro two hints allow
us to give a little more information to
the browser and say hey look these ads
are of low importance they're a script
which traditionally while this would be
high or medium priority depending on
where it is in the page because it's a
synchronous script but what we can
actually say is important equals low we
could say it's it's ads they're not that
important to the page I'd rather the
load first party content this again is
in its infancy I believe it's still
behind a flag in Chrome but priority
hints is absolutely something to keep an
eye on and the last tip which is the
worst one it's such a cop-out it's so
lazy of me you're gonna hate me for this
it's just restraint just get by with as
little as possible for as long as
possible that's probably the most
meaningful way of avoiding third-party
issues don't install a second tag
manager alright don't install a third
font provider try and get by with as
little as possible for as long as
possible and that renders the previous
46 minutes kind of completely obsolete
right so if you can get away with as
little as possible for as long as
possible
that's absolutely what I would recommend
you'd be very patient very gracious
that's me shutting up now saying thank
you I'm around for the rest of the day
so if anyone does have questions come
and grab me but thank you for listening
you